non marine le pen a tenu un long
discours d'environ une heure et l'a fait
un emprunt d'une minute ou une minute et
demie à elle sans discours de françois
fillon
ça montre que marine le pen n'est pas
sectaire et que lorsque un de ses
concurrents l'occurrence du premier tour
parle bien de la france est bien elle
peut c'est une stratégie ses propos oui
c'est totalement assumée c'est un clin
d'oeil assumait c'est un petit emprunt
ça montre ça montre bien que voilà qu'on
peut se nourrir aussi parfois de qui
aille au delà a écrit ce design des
propos des autres on parle de par paul
marie coûteaux non je ne sais pas qui a
écrit mais c'est pas tellement la
question
voilà françois fillon avait bien parlé
de la france dans un discours au puy en
velay je crois il ya une quinzaine de
jours au la marine le pen reprend ce
propos voilà je pense que c'est une
façon aussi de direction est vital parce
qu'il s'agit de valade de parler du pays
de parler de la france de passer quand
même aux promos oui non mais totalement
assumée encore une fois c'est pas un
plagiat
si on avait voulu cacher ou dissimulé eh
bien on n'aurait pas fait un discours
d'il ya quinze jours qui étaient publics
étaient en plein campagne présidentielle
et sa vie tel en effet le pen que
c'était du plagiat cas quel employé des
mots de françois fillon a nommé encore
une fois c'est assumer c'est pas du
plagiat et le savait alors écoutez vous
lui posez la question mais oui il s'agit
simplement pour nous deux un petit clin
d'oeil d'un petit emprunt est-ce que
c'est pas fâcheux qu'elle est passée
proprement pour parler de la france
marine le pen à la fin d'un discours
d'une heure et elle fait des discours
tous les deux jours qui sont ses propres
mots donc il il s'agit pas d'avoir
besoin d'utiliser les mots d ordre il
s'est simplement roland j'ai alors eu
des propos qui finalement peuvent
dépasser un peu les clivages